[Music]
mandy
is in savannah georgia hi mandy welcome
to the dave ramsey show
hi thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
um so my husband and i are on baby step
two um
and he has had the opportunity to come
up to join the
army national guard they are telling him
that he will have
a twenty thousand dollar enlistment
bonus
and it's a six year commitment and they
will also
do over a three-year period they'll pay
off his student loan debt
in thirds um so we were just kind of
weighing our options of is this a good
choice for us we have about 58 000
left in our debt snowball
and we didn't want to make a rash
decision and sign him up for something
for six years
but it also seems like it could be god
opening a door for us to
really you know make a step forward in
our finances and so we just wanted to
get some feedback okay
uh the benefits package with the
national guard is excellent
uh we endorse them we tell people to do
the national guard
the 20 000 sign up and the third's
forgiven over three years is pretty
amazing
all of that is wonderful uh but
just like anything else if it's not
something he's called to he's going to
be miserable
and so
just for money and truthfully the better
people around the national guard will
tell you
not to do this unless you feel called to
do it don't do it just for the money
do it because it's what you're called to
and oh there's some great money
yes um he's currently a firefighter um
has always said that his big regret
is not joining the military when he had
the opportunity when he was younger okay
so i think i think it would lend that i
think the other part
of our our problem is that he would be
gone for
six months-ish for training and we have
a blended family with five kids
so um we're thinking a short-term
sacrifice of six months
for this long-term gain and something
that he's wanted to do might be a good
idea but again we didn't want to make a
wrong decision
yeah well i i think the only way you
would sign up for
the adventure that's going to be yours
mandy because he i mean
he's got training you got boot camp
right holy crap and so i mean
everybody on this in this story has got
to be signed up kids
how old are the kids um
goodness so um he has a five-year-old
and a six-year-old i have a
seven-year-old
eight-year-old and thirteen-year-old and
you got custody of all of them
um no i have 50 50 custody um a great
relationship with my ex-husband so they
go back and forth
and then we have his about
seven or twenty five percent of the time
okay would you have them
during the six months would you take
them some of the time
um we're hoping so if his ex-wife will
agree to that um but that's our big
concern too is that they don't see him
very often so by taking another six
months away
again but it's short-term pain on on
their end whether you're really young
in order for us to give them a better
life in the future right well and yeah
and for their dad to live out his
calling so i don't know ken
yeah i i think that uh the five and six
year old
six months time for them it's like a
time warp they don't know
and i think they're young enough it's
the right age to do this they really
they don't have a clue whether it's six
months or six minutes
so i i think you'd do it and uh it's
gonna be hard on his heart it's gonna be
hard on your heart obviously you all
being separated but dave's absolutely
right if
both of you are in agreement that this
is the right move for the big picture
uh purpose and money i like it i think
it's a good move i do it
yeah a lot lots of families uh commit to
something like this but the thing is
this
if you hate the idea of managing these
kids for six months
and you're not you know you're you're
less than enthused about it then it's
going to make the whole process
miserable
if he if he's not called to the military
it's going to make the whole process
miserable
and so and you know i assume the fire uh
fire department that he's with will
allow him to have the six months to do
his training and so forth so
you know but it sounds like everyone is
signed up here
and when i asked about the kids ages are
they signed up they do
he's ken's right they're more resilient
and they're less sensitive than we think
they are
they they survive a lot of stuff they're
pretty malleable
um but uh you know like when our kids
were that age
i'm trying to think let's see yeah
yeah i mean were you traveling a lot
when daniel i was just thinking like the
first book tour i was gone six weeks
yeah and uh you know daniel would have
been in that age group
yeah and so uh they would have been
pretty young yeah and so sharon had to
be signed up to saddle a bunch of young
kids in order for us to hit the goal of
getting the first book out there and
you know it's on the book on the new
york times the first time i go out on
book tour but i was about six weeks
and i did have a a break in the middle
of it but uh
but i mean and i did that three times
and one time i was gone 40 days
but um with total money makeover it was
the most intense one
uh but but in each case what we did was
we signed everybody up for the trip
it's like okay here's what we're doing
we're going to pay a price here
and then the blessings that are going to
come financially
you know when i get home we're going to
disney world you know and you know
there's
there's a carrot at the end of the stick
kind of a thing and
um but but if everyone involved has
decided they're all going to be
miserable while you're doing this
then everybody's going to be miserable
yeah you know so that that's the trick
and i think
it sounds like they're all on board
there yeah and i i don't see
and you get 20 000 bucks and you get a
third of your student loans forgiven for
three years
oh so boom that that that's going to
help them they're going to be debt-free
the kids are going to be fine this comes
down to you it comes down to you mama
and it comes down to him and and he's
wanted to serve he's always wanted to do
it it's a no-brainer
uh the kids that the five and
six-year-old they just want goldfish and
they watch their favorite program
they're going to be fine they don't even
know
do not sweat the five and six year old
and i are not like
nurturing dads are we we're not we're
not soft i just have been through it
and i know that and here's the other
thing now i'm on the other side where
the 15 year old doesn't even want to be
in the same room with me
i mean we think our kids need us so much
no they really don't
they don't want to be around us and
that's part of it i'm learning to grasp
that but it's okay it's gonna be all
right